welcome to this video playing step by
step yeah this is one of those guys we
have a terrible score against five point
five out of 15 that's really bad and
okay let's see how how I'm faring with
the Zurich variation guys playing this
with Bishop b2 that's done the best line
for what yeah III died he obviously
knows what he's doing this is a very
decent way to play giving black giving
wide them some chances for a slight edge
at least our able to play this quickly I
have fun got my fair share of experience
at least them while writing the book you
know looked at looked at this for quite
a long time nitey for I can go Bishop g7
sacrificing a porn I believe but why
exactly am I able to do that I forgot
but it didn't play 94 so it's not
relevant
yeah here white white and does enjoy the
the bishop pan but black has a very
sound structure so it's not easy at all
to one to break down okay is he going to
play F form it looks like he wants to
play that
and care for I don't really see a good
tactical way to play against that okay I
can crack and just like I have this
Queen III check idea but I wonder if
this is really going to work like night
f4 takes Queen III check and it looks
kind of candle weird Jim that's not very
active not sure it's a good idea to play
like that yeah so if he goes f4 can I
take on f4 twice take the ignite f4 rook
takes Queen nice feature group f 2 23 at
the ng7 hang so so he's preparing that I
wouldn't I am f5 or not at least at
least this grab some space yeah so his
his long diagonal is opened up that's
nice for him but there are also some
drawbacks I've gained some space and I
can maybe play the five I don't know if
it is a good idea though should I play
the five or not he's got night b3 to
deform yeah maybe regroup this should be
a six looking at the pawn this was one
IDM
maybe c5 is some move we should be two
CD sixes this could be a problem okay so
he's got this backwards sepan but my
deep one is also an issue so he just
decides to clarify matters interesting
okay so hook is G form this looks kind
of problematic d5 I can also bring the
king and then go for d5
then d5 yo now that should be okay
should be about equal by getting d5
don't think I can do something active
yeah he wants to take and give the check
yeah i think i think i can actually do
that give up their five porn it's not
not a huge deal i hope i hope i'm seeing
this correctly Jeff Jeff Jeff it's not
even taking interesting he wants to go
for Bishop g8 Wow ok
all right it's very strong
wow that was very strong g5 I tried to
play with this idea of trapping his
bishop maybe maybe this is a possible
defense king bishop takes King f7 g7
time warning if he this is this is
really tricky if he plays Bishop age 7
and I get in King g7 his bishop is
completely trapped so he didn't do it
maybe can take now
check
yeah that wasn't wasn't good really I
lost lost ton of tons of time here
yeah bishop h5 is the problem maybe I
can still defend King e66 don't see at
the moment how he how he wins can I get
suked smoked maybe don't see it at the
moment though check draw a third a
bishop g8 now I stumbled into this
nonsense I now of course I was bad the
whole time so okay black forfeits on
time Ja
yeah g5 was very strong Wow now I didn't
see that one and he is here this is very
interesting is g5 this is much stronger
than taking the ng5 wow that was really
strong what kind of want some people i
read this is what he sends me right yeah
sitting there teach me master yeah I
don't know yeah that was really i mean
now now i'm back of course theme here
screw this and came up as well let's see
what does he supposed to do h4 h5 is
just wrong i am ok Sharon right here
that's really not much going on but I
have to be more precise probably this is
just I think this should be ok I just
have to be be precise then see you went
here
probably ok this is ok but king is six
already is a problem right but I should
really go here I am and then get the
bishop over them now that's it's better
right I get it here that should be ok
yeah this is an interesting very
interesting endgame here check check
check yeah g5 was much stronger than
taking ok here we should she ate yeah
yeah I really I just barely have this
this this defense age for was so
stronger yeah now my problem is if i go
here he can take and he just keeps this
pawn I already don't know what I can do
it I can play this then aged five yeah
and now whom he's finally able to play
this and here here here you can go
Bishop g6 it doesn't have to go pawn to
g6 and this was this was them the
logical follow-up to g5 which would have
which would have won this is yeah here
here i should draw actually but it's
it's it's not much fun of course but i
lost some time here with this stuff
maybe it is still lost as possible yeah
it's possible that I lose by by some
some some some tempos oops wrong
maneuver it's possible yeah it's
definitely not much fun to to defend
here edgy 54 strong really strong say a
way to avoid the structure probably not
right yeah I think I think this is the
key idea should should go here ready and
see maybe I can also play it in a more
active way yeah like if he gets here I
can try something like that yeah I'm
trying to get something going against
this pawn now there should be something
that with precise player should hold but
it's not it's not much fun of this thing
okay well thanks for watching